my name is Terry Crews and I'm going to
make a recipe that has been in my family
for over 25 years
Mac and GZ it's not a very saucy kind of
mac and cheese but it's got the cheese
the cottage cheese is the secret
ingredient it kind of does the whole
saucy thing and blends everything
together if you can find cream style
cottage cheese I actually works best but
a lot of times a lot of places don't
sell it so I always go with the small
curd but it really feels extra cheesy my
wife and I were married 27 years and
this is what we do everything's giving
every time it's time for a life to get
really down and heavy with food it's a
very very filling satisfying dish and I
say it's for my cheat day and I don't
use butter just simply because it's so
cheesy already you know the coconut oil
really adds a nice little flavor to it
it's satisfying and in its simplicity I
like to add a little extra cheese on top
and then the paprika it really helps
with the Browning and when you bake it
the old Magadh GZ my mother had made it
and then I got a chance it's that
everything is giving every Christmas but
it also hits the summer barbecue because
obviously I never have any of this left
it's only for special occasions because
I would not be in shape I would just be
heating maca GZ all day long mmm